تسعى فرنسا الى زياده انفاقها العسكري
ليتناسب مع تحديات دوليه كبيره على راسها
الحرب في اوكرانيا مساء اعلن عنها الرئيس
الفرنسي خلال لقائه مع قاده وافراد قوات
المسلحه في قاعده جويه جنوبيه البلاد
من اجل تجديد ادواتنا العسكريه التي تصون
حريتنا وامننا وازدهارنا
وتنفقوا فرنسا حاليا على ميزانيه الدفاع
295 مليار يورو لكن مع اعلان مكروه سيرفع
حجم الانفاق بنحو الثلث ليصبح
413 مليار يورو بين عام 2017 و 2030 خطوه
لها دلالات كثيره
الشده نكتشفها في اوروبا
وفي سياق الحرب الاوكرانيه دول عديده
تقدمت نحو هذا التوجه في اوروبا سبقت
المانيا جارتها فرنسا بخطوه الى الامام مع
اعلانها رفعها الانفاق العسكري الى 100
مليار يورو لكن المساله عندما تخرج عن
الرئيس الفرنسي لها ابعاد اكبر خصوصا وان
فرنسا قوه الردع النووي الوحيده في القاره
وعند الحاجه ستكون باريس خط المواجهه
الاول في وجه التهديد النووي فادي الدهوك
العربيه باريس